en garde des européens se sont
multipliés les derniers temps la
présidente de la commission européenne
ours ou la faune der leyen a brandi la
menace de mesures sans précédent si la
russie décidé d'envahir à nouveau
l'ukraine c'est ce qui devrait
apparaître dans les conclusions des 27
aujourd'hui l'idée étant de faire
pression sur moscou pour obtenir la
désescalade alors vous le savez en début
de semaine les européens ont déjà pris
des sanctions contre le groupe wagner
cette société privée para militaires
russes qui est présente dans plusieurs
conflits comme ensuite comme en syrie
mais également dans plusieurs pays
africains et d'autres sanctions sont
également en préparation cette fois en
coordination avec les états unis le
royaume uni et le canada en fait les
européens veulent être prêts en cas
d'invasion ans mais on le sait aussi la
question russe a tendance à diviser le
bloc européen il ya d'un côté les pays
qui sont partisans de la moitié de la
manier de la manière forte comme la
pologne les pays baltes et la suède et
puis il ya de l'autre des pays qui
veulent au contraire privilégier le
dialogue comme l'allemagne la france la
grèce ou l'italie d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
olaf scholz et emmanuel macron hier ont
rencontré le président ukrainien qui
était présent à bruxelles dans le cadre
du sommet du partenariat oriental
rencontre à l'issue de laquelle les
biens volés de mire zéline ce qui s'est
dit prêt à des pourparlers mais a
également souligné sa volonté de voir
appliquer des sanctions préventive
contre la russie